esto es un stand con motivo del día
mundial de la lucha contra las
violencias machistas con peligrosos
retos que da tienes
15 has estado en una situación en la que
haya sido víctima de violencia
y él ya no tiene derecho a acercarse a
mí de acuerdo lo que es importante es no
quedarte sola y la acción es la única
asociación de francia que luche contra
las violencias machistas utilizando
exclusivamente los eventos y la cultura
parte del principio de que el silencio
mata por lo que esta asociación leonesa
decidió llevar a cabo acciones visibles
y públicas el objetivo es concienciar a
la sociedad
tenemos el violentómetro un instrumento
que nos permite situarnos en nuestra
relación de pareja funciona muy bien las
personas con las que hablamos no
hubieran venido porque hay una
exposición o una manifestación sino que
entramos en contacto con la gente porque
nos acercamos a ella
las violencias machistas afectan a todas
las mujeres de todas las culturas edades
y clases sociales en francia una de cada
diez mujeres las sufren dentro del
ámbito de la pareja por eso el festival
rompemos el silencio multiplica cada año
los talleres de expresión cultural las
proyecciones de películas teatros para
reventar la burbuja del tabú
islote escaso metros
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hay escenas que son muy incómodas hay
momentos en los que cerré los ojos es
una menor sola que está completamente
sola de hecho sin adultos el único
adulto abusa de su autoridad de su poder
sobre ellas
soy presidente de un club deportivo
es verdad que cuestiona muchas cosas
efectivamente en los clubes hay que
asumir nuestra responsabilidad quizás
abrir los ojos no sea a partir de qué
edad pero decirles vas a estar en
confianza con esta persona pero atención
a tiene derecho a decir que no y hacerte
preguntas
i
[Música]
en europa una de cada tres mujeres
mayores de 15 años ha sufrido alguna
forma de violencia física o sexual